so winsome sears is the new lieutenant
governor elect of the state of virginia
she's a black republican who doesn't
support the left's racial grievance
politics she's thinking for herself and
that of course is intolerable on the
left on msnbc a guy called michael eric
dyson who's a professor at georgetown
university accused winsome sears of get
this being a black white supremacist
honestly this is one of the most
disturbing and
to put it bluntly racist attacks we've
ever seen here it is
they want white supremacy by
ventriloquist effect there is a black
mouth moving but a white idea through
the running on the runway of the tongue
of a figure who justifies and
legitimates of the white supremacist
practices we know that we can
internalize in our own minds in our own
subconscious and our own bodies the very
principles that are undoing us so to
have a black face uh speaking in behalf
of a white supremacist legacy is nothing
new
horace cooper is the co-chair of project
21 and he joins us now horace great to
see you tonight
i don't think it's surprising to hear
such vile and absurd rhetoric coming
from the two individuals we just saw on
that screen but it is surprising horus
that msnbc and their parent company
comcast seem okay with it
well it is very disappointing you know
there was a time when cable companies tv
companies radio networks all had a code
that said
as we're going to voluntarily comply
with this idea we won't promote racism
we won't promote bigotry
they apparently at msnbc have walked
completely away from that and if you
just took the video off and just played
the audio you would assume
some
uh racist or segregationist from the
1940s was talking
in the way that they attribute
to
race certain ideas and certain thoughts
that's really dangerous it's actually
quite evil
oh no doubt about it horse help me out
let me see if i translate it correctly
if you are black you must think one and
only one way that's what i heard and
it's not the first time i've heard it
from the likes of michael eric dyson
if you are black
you can't be an astronaut if you are
black
you can't be an elected official if you
are black you need to stay in your place
that's what the segregationists have
said now i'm going to remind the
audience
that in the 19th century one political
party decided that it was going to make
race the primary issue
disparaging one group and promoting
another when we had a civil war and we
thought that was settled that one
political party came back again in the
20th century and they set up jim crow
with the idea that race explains
everything and your abilities and your
talents don't
we had martin luther king and the civil
rights movement
millions of people like myself grew up
in this post martin luther king period
but now
the woke races are back in the 21st
century and once again they posit your
race determines your role your function
and your options that's bigotry 101
regardless of what century it comes from
yeah horus it's everything is upside
down it seems that those who call
themselves anti-racist
are the most racist those who today
advocate for racial empathy are at the
simultaneously advocating for racial
segregation how did and we don't have
much time left together [ __ ] here but
how did we end up in this place where in
order to be protected from being called
a racist the best way to behave is to
actually be a racist
well let's remember that in the 19th and
the 20th centuries those advocates of
bigotry said they weren't doing it to
disparage anyone they were doing it
because it was great for everyone the
same idea still obtains today don't
worry about what they say look at what
they're doing and what they're doing is
separating people on the basis of race
horse cooper really insightful stuff the
individual how radical of an idea
celebrate honor look at the individual
thanks for being with us tonight horace
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else